when it comes to pizza it's not just
taste that wins over the critics you
might need athleticism to this is the
world pizza championship in Parma
northern Italy and it's taken pretty
seriously from classic capriccio sirs
and mouth-watering marinara's to 12
one's a little more like bowls of fruit
more than 600 pizza makers from over 30
countries dish out the dough to be
crowned the world's very best but if
you're a fan of a meat feast or a full
house you all know connoisseur you'll
end at all even bottle every second so
welcome in on by banning the biggest
mistake in pizza making is using more
than four or five toppings people won't
understand what kind of taste you're
trying to achieve and it's also bad for
your health as well as taste the pizza
makers are judged on technique
creativity and presentation and the
international competitors know that if
they want to do well they've got to
revisit the pizzas roots we try to make
kind of what Italians make here so we
try to conform our recipes at home but
this is more than just a pizza party
it's big business according to the
organizers
if we think of the annual turnover
generated worldwide by the pizza
business we're talking about 72 billion
euros and it's a growing business
despite the crisis which explains why
these chefs really come here to compete
they're betting a top prize could mean a
thick slice of cash comes back to their
restaurants